[Music]
the term multiplayer games is like wide
and varied we want to talk about very
specific types of games but sort of put
some constraints on it so the types of
multiplayer games we want to talk about
is your fast-paced online competitive
multiplayer games right for example like
your overwatch is or your fortnight's or
your rocket leagues things like that
they have very particular types of needs
that come down to like matchmaking and
dedicated game server scaling that we're
gonna talk about today and those are the
type of games that we want to talk about
today there's there is a wide variety of
multiplayer games but these are the
projects that we want to talk about
today and the projects that we both work
on as well so some of you may be
familiar with this some of you may be
not this is generally speaking what a
traditional architecture would look like
for an online multiplayer game there are
a variety of ways in which one can do
this just so I'm clear this is a very
prevalent way of doing it that could be
a whole other talk in and of itself um
but in this particular example we might
have a couple of players that want to
play our game they're like cool let's
play a game that sounds awesome and so
they're gonna connect to some kind of
matchmaker usually a matchmaker will
look at things like your skill level
maybe your social graph who your friends
are put you together in a group so that
they can like pair you together so they
think you're gonna have a really good
gameplay experience once they've got you
and put you in this group they're gonna
go talk to some kind of game server
manager we use this term dedicated game
server and some of you may not be
familiar of it basically it is a full
simulation of the game that happens
somewhere on the internet that your
players are therefore going to connect
to this means that they can share
information about what's happening
inside the game the dedicated game
server can tell all the players hey this
is what's going on and it also gives us
some control in that we can place these
game servers around the world and what
sort of latency speed we can expect
because we have a basic idea of speed of
light and network speeds and good things
like that so this game server managers
job is basically to say okay I probably
have
huge number of machines they're probably
distributed around the world and I need
to say okay let's go find the machine
that has some CPU resource available and
some memory and step up a game server
process on them and then get that going
and then find the port and then send
that all the way back down the pipe back
down to the matchmakers so that those
game servers can get an IP import
because they're gonna connect to an
individual process on the machine and
then those game players will both
connect to the same IP import on one of
those machines to that dedicated game
server for instance so they can play a
game together right so they're gonna
share that simulation and this is like
how a lot of games that we all play if
people play online games I'm guessing
you do because many of you are here how
a lot of them work but a lot of this is
usually a lot of the time very bespoke
you kind of have to do it yourself you
have to build it yourself and that's
hard a lot of work and I don't know I
find an interesting problem but I'm
guessing a lot of people don't so we
want to talk about today's two very
particular things one here is
matchmaking wouldn't it be lovely if
there was some sort of maybe open source
standardized matchmaking framework type
thing that helps solve this problem and
then also here when we talk about this
game server manager at coordinating game
servers over lots of machines wouldn't
it be nice if there was some sort of
open source standardized game server
manager type thing wouldn't that be
lovely so let's talk about both of those
but before we get into that we mentioned
this a little bit previously kubernetes
is at the core of both of the solutions
we're gonna be talking about today and I
just want to highlight this for three
very important reasons both of these
projects run on top of cribben Eddy's in
slightly different ways and we'll talk
about that in a bit but this is really
important there are several reasons one
of which is simplicity so usually when
talking to game companies that run say
services such as matchmaking but also
game servers they run very different
platforms for both having a single
platform for both of these workloads
means that there's a simplification of
the knowledge you need in your team the
tools you need to use all that kind of
stuff that makes that much easier for
your teams to basically either get up
and running and also do your like day
three day four kind of operations I
think it goes without saying as many it
was probably quite knowledgeable about
there's a huge ecosystem of tooling here
right not only did this with kubernetes
not just built by Google but
variety of partners that did this work
and there's all the tooling that goes on
around it finally and I think most
importantly especially for dedicated
game servers sometimes you just need to
put game servers and these kinds of
latency sensitive sensitive applications
in weird places around the world just
cuz sometimes players just show up in
odd places and you need to put them
there and maybe your cloud covers it
maybe we have great gk coverage they're
awesome that maybe sometimes we don't so
having a standardized platform like
kubernetes means that you can take your
entire stack and put it exactly where
your players need and that's really
important to us so let's get stuck in
all right so we're gonna start talking a
little bit about open match this is a
framework that we co-founded last year
with unity it was announced at unite
Berlin last summer if you are interested
in learning more about the founding of
it and our relationship with unity I
recommend you go check out the talk on
YouTube about that we were really
focused in this project on solving a lot
of the really basic plumbing problems of
matchmaking like getting players
connected to the matchmaking service
integrating the matchmaking service with
your back-end infrastructure but leaving
the bits in the middle which is like
your custom matchmaking logic up to you
not really being prescriptive about that
at all so it's very flexible it's
designed with api's that are
horizontally scalable so you can handle
your player load even if you end up with
a really big hit and it's designed as I
said integrate well with your existing
processes or other tools that you want
to use it is written in golang but your
own custom matchmaking logic you can
write in any language you can put in a
docker container so how it works the
game clients will connect to the API
that open match exposes for the front
end they pass in all of the different
attributes that you might want to try
and match players on developers then
write these custom matchmaking functions
like I mentioned before that can be in
any language you want the only
real requirements is you have to be able
to package it in a docker container
because this does run on kubernetes and
it needs to be able to talk to Redis
which is the back back-end state storage
for open match it allows you to run a
lot of these matchmaking functions
concurrently which is both a way to
handle scale and use the ability that
kubernetes has to schedule as
automatically for you but also to enable
you to try to iterate really rapidly on
this logic piece that is most important
to you as a game developer of how do I
figure out which players play together
so let's start with a demo and then I'll
dive in a little bit further in a minute
on the actual architecture can we switch
to the demo that's great awesome so what
I have here is an empty kubernetes
cluster
I mean quickly show you that there's
nothing in it
also important to note up front I am NOT
very good at typing and talking at the
same time I'll do my best but I'm not
not great at that
so right now this project is set up with
a number of images I've already pulled
them set them up in the project most of
these images are available publicly from
the open mesh repository and we have a a
public container registry you can pull
these from but you can see I've already
got the images there so the first thing
I'm going to do is just install open
match and kind of lets you see what the
process of that is like so you can see
how simple it is first thing I'm going
to do is create a kubernetes config map
this contains all the configuration for
open match if anyone here has actually
gone and looked at the open match
repository and seeing what the
configuration looks like I am applying
almost exactly the one that's in the
example on the repository the only
difference you can probably guess from
the title there is I turned off the
debug logging because that does not make
for a good demo so first of all we're
going to stand up an instance of Redis
is just running Redis within kubernetes
there is a it is utilizing a kubernetes
secret for its password username and
password to login to Redis
now I'm going to install open match this
is a series of kubernetes deployments
and services in front of them it makes a
few let me show you those so you can see
here we have now six pods running so
Redis and then five services from open
match that's the om at the beginning of
those these are run as deployments
something were to happen kubernetes will
take care of starting it back up for you
it also allows you to very easily scale
those deployments if you get a big hit
and you need to handle more players so
first thing I'm going to do after
actually standing up open match is stick
some players in open match this part is
going to take just a second because it
has to pull down the image I just made a
brand new cluster for this demo so what
this particular pod is going to do is
spin up this pod just like those other
images that I showed you earlier are
just available for public on the open
match public registry but it's going to
spin up it's going to queue 10,000
players in open match seven times that's
the seven cycles with 10,000 players per
cycle this is just to get a bunch of
players in so I can actually show you
what it looks like when ever open match
is doing your matching logic so I'll let
that run it'll take just a second and
then I have a match maker that is
written against open match and I used
that kind of language intentionally open
match is not in itself a match maker it
is a framework for writing scalable
match makers on top of kubernetes so
this is the example match maker which is
currently on the repository it's not
very big
I think it's probably 220 or 250 lines
of code therefore it is really basic but
what it does allow me to do is run a lot
of concurrent matchmaking functions so
you can kind of see how scaling works in
open match so in general the approach of
open match is like you have this very
player population mine right now is
70,000 people I'm going to try and split
up that population into a few different
chunks and then look within all of those
chunks simultaneously for matches so
allow me to like give a lot of matches
at once without having to chew through
all of the players and giant piles of
sequential code I one of my deployments
sometimes takes a minute to start so the
first loop occasionally I didn't give it
long enough to start up for the demo but
you can see here I'm looking for two
teams of eight four times in four
different parts of the player population
you can see the pools here they're
between ten and fifteen thousand players
roughly per pool within those pools I'm
only looking for 16 players so this
didn't take very long at all you can see
I ran all four of those concurrently and
like just a little over two seconds so
that's not very interesting in terms of
scale of a match is definitely designed
to go a lot wider than that so it's now
I'm gonna split it up into four hundred
different buckets that I'm looking for
players in and you're gonna see a lot of
these go by with insufficient players
that means the part of the player
population I'm looking at there
literally aren't even sixteen players in
that part of the population to make a
match out of so what this is
demonstrating is running 400 copies of
your match logic concurrently this
usually takes around 20 or 30 seconds to
complete yeah 24 seconds so we ran 400
copies about 2/3 of those found a match
the other third did not because I was
looking at parts of the population where
there just weren't enough players there
you can see this got us a lot more
throughput though this matched 4288
players and managed to match about a
hundred and eighty players per second
that it was searching so that's kind of
how you achieve scale with open match so
can we go back to the slides I'm gonna
briefly go over the architecture and
then Mark's gonna talk about using a go
nay's
so this architecture show is basically
the same diagram that mark showed
earlier only we've taken that box that
just said matchmaker and blown it up
to show you all the parts of open match
so to begin with the game client we
talked to the open match front-end the
front-end writes the player tributes to
Redis your server manager which can be
anything maybe you have bespoke code
maybe you're using an off-the-shelf
solution maybe you're using agonies I
recommend it would talk to the backend
API of open match that kicks off your
custom match logic your custom match
logic gets to read and write data from
Redis it can read and write it directly
if you need that level of
customizability we also offer an API in
front of Redis to do really common
matchmaking things like filtering
players or retrieving large pools of
players from Redis at once the server
manager will then figure out which
players go on which servers so it'll
probably pick a server get the IP import
of that server that gets actually passed
back out through open match to your game
client app which at this point goes in
connects directly to the dedicated game
server that's all real similar to what
Mark showed you earlier so this is
already an improvement but we still have
some kind of bespoke server management
system so Mark's gonna talk to us about
replacing that with a go nice mark
awesome so yeah like Joseph says like we
have this other part that we also need
to replace so strangely enough ok so we
have another open source project called
OCONUS for orchestrating scaling and
hosting your dedicated game servers this
has been a fun project we've been
working on it for actually over a year
now now I think about it and it is built
as an extension of kubernetes that we'll
see in a minute so it's basically I
think that puts itself inside kubernetes
so if suddenly kubernetes is like
awesome I know how game servers work
this is actually really important if
people are not familiar with dedicated
game servers they have this interesting
thing where they go from stateless to
stateful so when you don't have any
players on a game server no one seems to
mind if you kill them you mean you have
players on a game server people get
really upset if you just ruin their
gameplay experience they post things on
reddit it's awful no one likes that
so Agana is is real capability and part
of its core strengths is really managing
that transition between the two now
what's really awesome is we didn't do
this alone
much like joseph was talking about with
open match they built that in
collaboration with unity we've been
working on this quite closely with
Ubisoft since the beginning it's been a
really great collaboration between us
they've been able to bring sort of their
their experience and their knowledge
around how to run large game server
workloads and we have been able to bring
our knowledge to work on kubernetes and
open source community so it's been
really great and we've also got
contributions from a wide variety of
other people since then as well so let
I'm gonna actually show you how to do
some stuff on agonism where I'll
actually show you some code and you can
actually see how it happens so
potentially unsurprisingly if you want
to start having a game server and
running it on kubernetes and running it
on our gun is it goes inside a container
nothing more special than that I'm sure
that's something a lot of you are very
familiar with the only special thing
Court unquote that we have is we do have
an integrated client SDK that goes into
the game server we have options
available in C++ go rest we actually
have a rust one as well it's getting
updated soon this is all either gr PC
based or rest based so the real short
answer here is if you have a language
that needs support we have an SDK for
you I actually realize we also have an
ojs one and it's not on my slide because
it just came in the most recent release
and I haven't updated the slide yet but
yeah if you want to integrate it we can
do it and this SDK is really just about
managing game server health lifecycle
which is just a little bit different
knowing whether the game server is ready
to accept players or not looking at the
configuration and things like that
basically standard things you need for
game servers so I said before that a gun
is an extension of kubernetes so when
you've used kubernetes and I think a lot
of you have right you're very familiar
with services with deployments right you
have these nouns that exists inside
kubernetes well once you install it on
is now this new noun called game server
is a reality so we can say to kubernetes
Hagerman at ease I would really like a
game server
I would really like to name this game
service anodic which is the example
we're actually gonna use today it's a
free-to-play open-source fps
and then we can specify things about
this game server specs that we want to
have available to us
so one of the things that argon is also
does is set up that direct port
connection so it'll do that dynamic port
allocation for you to set up the port
that that information is routed to with
inside the game server container so here
we specify that the game server is gonna
start on port 2600 but it's dynamic so
it's gonna give us a port once we're
done and finally we're gonna say hey
what's my game server container welcome
what have I actually put in here now for
those of you who are more familiar with
kubernetes which many of you are you
have a full pod spec here so if you want
to do config Maps following amounts
multiple containers etc etc you're fine
now this is great for a single server in
production in reality when you really
want to do this usually what you want to
do is actually have a large group of
priests pun game servers that are
sitting there idle waiting for players
sometimes game servers can take a little
while to spin up so much as we have pods
and deployments inside kubernetes we
have game servers and fleets
so fleets again like we were talking
about previously a very aware of that
change in life cycle between stateless
and stateful we'll go a little bit into
that in a minute but here we have a
fleet it looks very much like a
deployment in that we specify how many
replicas we want it can be - it can be
2000 up to you and then we have a
template which is our game server
configuration and that's gonna spin up a
large chunk of game servers for us which
is awesome now the interesting question
you might have at this stage but mark
you make these direct connections to
these game servers by IP import I don't
have a load balancer I don't have any of
the usual tools that I may be familiar
with how do I get one of these out in
like an atomic manner so we have this
concept inside Agana is called an
allocation basically the job of an
allocation is to say hey out of this big
group of game servers can I please have
one atomically and set it to it what we
call an allocated state so we know that
it has players on it and just do that
work for me do it in the right way find
the right place inside there's cluster
etc etc so what we can do is we can send
another custom resource definition
another thing called a game
server allocation and we can say hey for
in this particular instance hey for this
particular fleet called synodic give me
one out of this pool handed back to you
atomically just give it to me
and set it to allocated and give me its
details please we can do actually a lot
more with game server allocation we've
got some pretty complex selector logic
in there if you need it but this is a
simple example so once we've done that
we can then play a game on it so why
don't I show you you that it's action
can I have a switch over to demo please
do thank you very much
it's that readable in the back thumbs up
perfect awesome
so first thing I'm going to do much like
Joseph we're going to install a GaN is
I'm gonna use helm
that's package manager to install going
as you can use straight UML if you want
Don is namespace kind of system so if
you're not familiar with how I'm helm is
a package manager for kubernetes to
basically install a bunch of stuff so
that's kind of it's complicated as it is
to get it up and running we want to see
the what we have in there a system right
so we have a bunch of things in there
there's a controller all sorts of stuff
but now we have a gun is installed now
kubernetes understands what game servers
are and this actually runs throughout
the entire system which I actually think
is really really excited so I can
actually say cube CTL get game servers
and this is something it now understands
it's gonna say we don't have any yet but
that's that's actually really really
cool so let's let's create a fleet of
game servers we saw that Sonata clone we
had previously so I'm gonna apply two
examples some notic fleet now everything
I'm gonna do here I'm just gonna do
through llamó files you may be very
familiar with this you could do this
through the crewmen Eddie's API as well
it's all kind of you can you can change
one for the other as needed so now I can
say hey game servers let's see if those
are up and ready and they are so we can
see here some information we have a
couple of game servers there remember
from the example we asked for having two
they're both in the state ready so
they're actually ready to be allocated
we can do stuff with them and that's all
super nice we can
look at this is from fleets as well
right we can see here we have two that
are ready but two Game Servers is boring
right
that's no fun I mean we're gonna get
really huge but we can scale fleet
replicas let's just say 200 what I need
to tell about fleet yeah there we go so
now we can put that up to 200 if we want
to look at that here we can get those
details that's gonna just gonna take a
little while to come up let's come on
you can do better there we go 74 but we
actually look at this in a different way
too and actually refresh this so we have
inbuilt gravano dashboards and metrics
that are available is that gone down in
between no that gonna run let's just
rerun that there we go there we go so we
have inbuilt metrics gravano dashboards
we can also export to stock driver
basically everything comes out through
through open census so you can send it
just about anywhere to do all the stuff
that you need to do as well to manage
your game servers so here we can see how
many are starting up how many are
allocated how many are ready this is
running a little slow behind usually it
pings about every 30 seconds there you
go that's better so 100 you can't see
that that's tiny but you can take my
word for it it's about a hundred eighty
six there we go
and we can see rates and there's a
variety of metrics that we can take
advantage of during this let's go we'll
go back to here so if we look at our
fleet alright so we have 200 ready they
came up pretty quick which is super nice
let's allocate one out of this this set
create a chef usually this would be
something you would probably do through
the API like your matchmaker would call
this and say hey can I allocate we might
show that a little later
allocation I'm gonna go - oh yeah Mel so
it'll return to me exactly the results
of what it's done so we'll do that I'm
not gonna worry about what's up top I'm
just gonna look at here so here we can
see we've got a particular game server
awesome it's been state has been set to
allocated and
here are its details so we have an IP in
a port so we'll do the fun thing that
everyone really wants to see is let's
actually play a game on here and see if
it works so for this network so I've
demo fun time yeah exactly
so let's run that I'm just gonna move
that over a touch so that I can see this
let's see if I can type it yeah perfect
excellent so this is so notic this is
this is the open source first-person
shooter that we were talking about
previously zero : where it was the
dynamically allocated port seven 162
click join black screen is actually good
I don't know why they just made the game
to give me heart attacks that's just
it's just how they like to roll
beautiful okay so now I'm gonna play
this on my trackpad which will be
hilarious let's see if I can find some
the other players that are about come on
this always happens whenever I'm playing
like alone like there's players
everywhere and then as soon as I get
like in front of an audience like
nobody's around there we go there's some
box so there's some Rockets yeah so this
is me playing or on a sonic ribbon a DS
cluster that's actually running us West
East no West would you ever won these
closest to us and it's all working right
like you can see I'm playing a game and
it's pretty awesome so that's cool but I
want to show off a few more things
before we we finish up this demo so I'm
just gonna close that we can see here we
have one game server that's allocated
right there's a player playing on it
let's allocate a couple more just want a
few more and maybe at this point in time
we actually like ah you know what this
version is not good let's let's scale it
down let's get rid of it so let's uh
let's do that let's keep CTL scale fleet
zoonotic replicas we're actually gonna
make it zero let's get rid of all of
them now players like I mentioned before
players will get mad if we kill the
games that they're playing so we don't
want that so what's what a ganas does is
it's very aware of that allocated game
server state so um fleets themselves we
could do rolling updates we could do
scale up and scale down but no matter
what happens it's always gonna say oh
that's allocated
I'm not gonna touch that so now if I
look my fleet there we go we can see we
still have three right we have those
three allocated game servers we're not
gonna touch those until they the self
shutdown or we specifically tell them to
be deleted so that's kind of one of the
big powers Oregon is is managing that
workload everything else on top of that
all the utilities we provide for game
servers is super nice but this is really
just the core of how agonised works
alyssum can we go back to the slides
please excellent so wouldn't it be
lovely if we were friends so let's talk
a little bit about putting together a go
nice and open match so for this session
we had a matchmaker built on open match
that understands and coordinates agonies
fleets there is customized matchmaking
logic that's running with an open match
to look for compatible players in this
case all it is looking for is that the
player said that it wanted to be part of
our GCP next demo so it's not
particularly exciting matchmaking logic
does show that it is possible once
enough players are found in this case we
are looking for a whopping two players
you want to play together the matchmaker
will allocate a ready game server from
the fleet and once that's been allocated
it'll send back out through open match
the connection details so that open
match can connect to the game server so
back to the demo do any of you watch
cooking shows any a couple of you okay
so this may be familiar I have a
pre-baked cluster that I'm going to pull
out of the oven right now so that you
don't all have to wait for me to spin up
a cluster sorry if I ran that command
you would have to wait let me switch
over to that so basically this is a
cluster that we made earlier it has
plenty of CPUs that already has a go
nice installed on it
I'll show you briefly what's running in
it
so in this case you can see it already
has open match installed this all looks
really familiar from the previous demo
although this is a different and
slightly larger cluster so first of all
let's put in a go any fleet in it so in
my case my fleet is a little bit
different it is not running zoonotic it
is running UDP - server which is the
most ridiculously simple UDP server we
could come up with all it is is a server
that takes UDP clients and echoes
timestamps to them once per second it
echos the epoch timestamp so it is about
as proof of concept as you can get
director is the name of this particular
pattern of a matchmaker I'm gonna stand
one of these up
so this matchmaker understands ygones
and is looking for a fleet called UDP
server it is currently looking at that
fleet if I were to show you logs from it
all you would see is an endless loop of
there aren't any players there aren't
any players there aren't any players
over and over again so I won't show you
that let me actually actually put some
players in so first thing this does is
put one player in that's significantly
less than the 70,000 I did last demo but
it's gonna pay off just give me a second
so we've got one head like headless
client queued for matching now I'm going
to queue an interactive client this part
can take a while huh it didn't you can
see it already got an assignment that
came from a go nice
so the matchmaker has already gone to
ygones issued via the kubernetes api and
allocate request gotten back the
allocation with this IP address and the
dynamically allocated port like mark
showed you earlier
that's this assignment right here and
now it's waiting for me to do something
so I'm going to connect to that UDP
server as I said before this is not the
most exciting demo you'll see at next
but it is a good proof of concept so if
I click start I am Telling that UDP
server hey start sending me
I'm stamps so if anyone's curious what
time it is in in UTC right now here you
go
so we can also stop this as a very basic
ripple built in so that unsubscribes me
then I can quit so once I quit it's
deleted my UDP client that game is still
running it still has the other player on
it now I'm just going to spin up some
headless clients two at a time for a
while and watch a go NACE this is
demoing something that is also really
awesome that a gun is can do for you
that is not in the demo that mark was
showing us earlier which is a go neighs
can do auto scaling so this is set up
with a fleet autoscaler Paulo policy
that says I want at least two available
ready servers at all times so every time
that it allocates all of the servers it
will go back to kubernetes and start up
more game servers for you to keep that
warm buffer he was talking about earlier
so this is basically just a bunch
numbers on the screen but you can see
that everything is working if I leave
this up here while I talk you will see
that slowly as my matchmaker is pulling
in players allocating servers from the
fleet and putting players on those
servers the fleet will then go behind
the scenes and start up a couple of more
servers two at a time is what I had it
set for because when I set it to 20
earlier it just shot up so fast that you
didn't see anything demo but the number
200 like he showed you before it wasn't
very exciting all right can we go back
to the slides please awesome so let's
talk about what that did here we're back
to the previous diagram only we've
collapsed back down that giant open
match box to be this nice little stack
in the corner so you can see we had the
players connecting to open match they
connected to the front end API that we
were talking about before
open match is running a matchmaker
inside of it that understands
and that's running the custom match
logic I talked about before looking for
these headless clients that are tagged
that they want to play in the next demo
as it finds those it talks to the
kubernetes api it asks for an allocation
from the fleet that reaches out to the
ygones controller the agonies controller
goes grabs a particular server moves
that server to allocated state gets the
IP and ported for that server sends that
back out open match to the game clients
which it's really hard to see on this
but that is a green line going back the
other way as opposed to the blue line we
have before and then those players
connect directly to that dedicated game
server and play now once you've got all
of this in place open match is capable
of scaling horizontally if you get a
really big hit game and you need to
handle a much larger player base than
you expected the go nice is capable of
handling basic auto scaling for you so
this can significantly cut down the
amount of development time you need to
do around building the nuts and bolts
part of your game back-end so mark you
want to talk a little bit about other
features sweet so we we showed a bunch
of stuff today there's a lot of work
that have gone into both of these
projects so there's a variety of stuff
that we haven't really talked about um
one of which I want to highlight again
sort of touched on that previously like
both of these projects works across
cloud providers there's nothing special
about the kubernetes that we're running
on nothing like that it all uses
standard kubernetes tooling across the
board on both of them joseph did touch
on this but there's fleet deployment
node or they're scaling basically both
projects have the capability to order
scale with your load so if you're
running in the cloud you have that
elastic ability to shrink and grow as
your requirements need birth projects
have local development tools so if you
want your developers to not necessarily
spin up an entire like kubernetes
cluster locally or they just want a
lightweight testing environment they
both have tools that were able to do
that
I showed up some of the metrics and
dashboards that are available in our
gonna is there's a whole lot more as
well as metrics and dashboards that are
available for open match as well yeah we
use all the same standards we also use
open sense
Prometheus and ger fauna yep so it's all
good stuff future developments I'll talk
a little bit about roadmap for organize
we're looking to hit one point over this
year that's a big broad statement that
gives us lots of room to wiggle I'm
happy with that which is good but we
have a lot more stuff we've been doing a
lot of performance improvements in the
last few releases but many more we're
looking to come we want to do more
metric collection display there's a wide
variety of metrics for game servers that
we want to gonna take advantage of and
then display for customers better
commercial engine integration right now
there's lots of people who are using
unreal and unity but we want to have
some standardized tooling around that
just to make life easier for people
Multi cluster and multi cluster
coordination we're looking at a variety
of ways on how we can do that and make
that easier for people as well and it
looks like in 1.14 we have some really
nice windows Hosting's we want to look
at how we can support that for game
developers especially a development time
where a lot of game developers use
windows but also supporting it in
production workloads as well you talk
about every match yeah so from the open
match standpoint unity has recently
contributed their design for a longer
lived matching logic which is to say you
can stand up the matching logic in
kubernetes and not spin it down in
between the cycles of your match makers
so it makes it very fast to kick off the
matchmaking logic it's already there and
running it'll just spin down and use
very little CPU whenever it's not
necessary
we're also expanding metrics and
dashboards were actually in the process
of doing another design iteration on
what metrics people want to get out of
open match so if you're interested in
that please come put your comments in
the issues on the github repository we
are going to be implementing player and
match tracings that you will be able to
pretty easily see when a player went
into your system what exactly they did
what all the processes they went through
which matchmaking functions considered
them which match they got put in which
server they ended up on that should all
be things that you should be able to
trace through whenever you need to debug
something or troubleshoot something or
just validate that things are working
the way that you expect to them we we
want that to all be built in and baked
in tools that we can all work towards
taking for granted and matchmaking and
fine
we're just now getting the full build
chain set up with make which is going to
kind of get all the fancy github badges
around you know see ICD whenever PRS get
merged in they're gonna need to be
validated so we are a slightly younger
project than go neighs we are only on
0.4 but we have plans to launch 0.5 soon
and shoutouts to the team that is
working hard to make that happen
fantastic before we run away I would be
remiss if I didn't mention if you want
to get in the ganas cluster up and
running you can find a gun is on the
Google cloud marketplace so if you want
a quick test cluster so that you can get
things up and running in agonised
installed you can basically Boop and
that's literally the noises it makes
Boop um so that you can get anacondas
cluster up and running and play with
some game servers on it and start
testing it out finally before we go
where can people go to learn more so
where to find us
this has the eventual URL home that open
match is going to live in we haven't
pushed to this site yet so don't be
surprised if you go look at it on your
phone immediately after the session if
it's not there yet but this is going to
be live on the internet in perpetuity so
by the time you're watching this on
YouTube later it's probably already
there if you need to go find more
details about it immediately please go
check out github or just google search
open match you can also follow myself on
Twitter that's my Twitter handle sweet
Agana is agony dev we have a full slide
there with documentation which will also
link you to a github repository you can
follow it on twitter at okones dev and
you can follow me on twitter at neurotic
I'll also mention that we both have very
active slack channels as well as Google
Groups so if you want to get involved
please come join us in slack we would
love to have more contributors the
diversity of impact and variety of
perspectives is very much appreciated we
both think that open source has a really
bright future in games so please come
and contribute absolutely finally before
we break into questions I just want to
mention my business cards it down here
so if you think you're gonna have a
question maybe in two months time or in
three weeks time but not right now
please feel free to come up and grab
some but finally yeah thank you so much
for taking the time to spend with us
your time is valuable so we appreciate
you spending with us and listening to us
without further ado we'll open the floor
up for questions
[Music]